[Applaudissements]
des scènes qui rappellent une autre
époque celle de la révolution de 2011 et
du printemps arabe
des dizaines de personnes arrêtées
plusieurs blessés dont certains membres
de la presse pourtant bien identifiable
[Musique]
depuis 2011 de 14 janvier est un jour de
commémoration en tunisie celui qui
marque le départ du dictateur ben ali
mais cette année le président a annulé
cet anniversaire officiel il a imposé un
couvre-feu deux jours avant et interdit
les manifestations
officiellement à cause de la pandémie
[Musique]
selon la police 1200 manifestants ont
défié l'interdiction
ils étaient bien plus nombreux selon
chaïma issa membre d'une coalition de
citoyens qui s'opposent au président
kaïs ça y est donc mes jambes j'ai pris
un coup de matraque mes amis aussi
chaque âge et j'ai quelqu'un qui est
déjà hospitalisé parce que il doit faire
une opération sur son bras donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a vu on n'a pas vu
pendant toute ces dernières à dix années
est aussi même ben ali n'a pas exclu
d'étendre de force surtout avait dans
les manifestations comme des milliers
d'autres tunisiens cette militante
s'oppose fermement ou décisions récentes
du président qui a concentré une grande
partie du pouvoir politique tunisien
entre cm
aujourd'hui avec son coup d'état il est
en train de nier tout ça est en train de
gommer notre
démocratie pour installer une dictature
aujourd'hui c'est une manière de
commémorer cette fête de la révolution
qui a été confisquée par le président
karzaï qui a décidé de manière
unilatérale de supprimer ce jour qui
était à précédemment un jour de
célébration nationale
aux
façades en juillet dernier le président
sayyed a limogé son gouvernement
fermé le parlement tunisien et entrepris
de gouverner par décret avec un petit
groupe de collaborateurs
il juge que le pays est devenu
ingouvernable
les partis d'opposition sont furieux en
particulier les députés du parti
islamiste ennahda il ne consulte
personne prend des décisions de manière
unilatérale
promulguer des décrets présidentiels et
gouverne la tunisie aujourd'hui d'un
coup de crayon de du palais de carthage
[Musique]
rosa après l'utiliser attendent toujours
de récolter les fruits de leur
révolution la vie est dure l'économie au
bord du gouffre la population les
syndicats et certains partis
d'opposition avaient donc d'abord appuyé
la démarche autoritaire du président en
espérant un déblocage de la situation
mais ces appuis s'effrite ce n'est pas
un secret
que les tunisiens sont déçus il y avait
des ambitions il y avait des attentes
mais malheureusement ses ambitions et
ses attentes n'ont pas trouvé un chemin
pour la concrétisation
le crin de la démocratie en tunisie est
toujours sur les rails il n'a pas
déraillé
devant la pression internationale le
président tunisien a lancé une vaste
consultation populaire
un référendum sur des changements
constitutionnels est prévue en juillet
et des élections générales suivant en
décembre problème la participation des
principaux acteurs n'est pas acquise
nous allons boycotter c'est je dirais
pièce de théâtre qui sont joués
uniquement pour blanchir le régime de
pyside ma crainte c'est que les
tunisiens et les tunisiennes
perdent l'espoir ou perdent leur
confiance en la démocratie et le rendez
vous électoral du 17 décembre 2022 je
crois consacrera cette ambition et cette
dynamique que j'espère évidemment
positive est porteuse de solutions a
coulé nouveau pour notre pays qui le
méritent fort ya comme un cadeau les
opposants réclament un réel dialogue
national pour résoudre cette crise degré
d'adhésion de la population au programme
du président déterminant la suite des
choses
[Musique]